unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground so we're at
the start of what's probably going to be
a very interesting week and there are
compelling things and funny things going
on one that's funny is funny not because
joe biden
is the be-all end-all of fixing america
or anything like it but it's
funny because it's a sign of just how
terribly the republican party has
performed
even for many republicans over the last
18 months
joe biden's approval rating in texas
among texas voters is higher
than texas's own republican governor
greg abbott if you can imagine the poll
conducted by the university of houston
hobby school of public affairs
has joe biden at a 41 approval rating
in texas whereas the republican governor
greg
abbott is only at 39 percent approval in
the state of texas
now there's a bunch of interesting
layers to this story and i hope to
get get to all of them or at least all
that i'm aware of the first
is that greg abbott is going to be up
for re-election in the year 2022
and there's talk of beto o'rourke
challenging him
we saw texas closer in the november of
2020 presidential election than it's
been in a very long time
and if these numbers remain where joe
biden is more popular than greg abbott
in texas it could be a really tough
re-election
and it could be an opportunity for a
democratic governor to actually win the
state of texas that would be
fascinating to see now second
this confirms that the high approval
that joe biden is experiencing
nationally we saw it at 63 percent early
last week or the week before
that is being supported not just by
democratic approval of joe biden
in blue states but it's also being
supported by higher than
typical approval for a democratic
president
from voters in red states including the
state of texas and then
the third aspect of this is that
right now at least much of what biden
has done
and much of what his approval is riding
on is his coronavirus response
i've been saying for weeks now just
move forward with the 1.9 trillion covid
relief package
that's been proposed by biden and by
democrats don't negotiate with these bad
faith republicans
let them all vote against it if that's
what they want to do and so far
democrats are moving in that direction
the approval numbers for biden overall
and uncovered response and the support
of the cobiad relief bill
to me signal that republicans are voting
against the bill at their own peril if
that's what they do what i mean by that
is
this coveted relief bill that joe biden
and democrats want is popular enough
with republicans that if republican
senators and members of congress all
want to oppose it
they are taking on significant political
risk for doing so now one
important caveat about abbott's approval
some republicans in texas don't like
greg abbott because he
did do a mask mandate so it's not all as
simple as
biden has a higher approval because
abbott didn't do enough
there are people upset with abbott in
texas because he didn't do enough
and there are people upset with abbott
because he did too much even though he
did a mask mandate it was basically
toothless
and uh it's sort of like the worst of
both worlds but the point here is that
even in texas
joe biden's approval higher than
republican republican governor greg
abbott's
and that's more evidence that the
country is crossing party lines
on what they want to see as far as covid
response is concerned
and if republicans become attached to we
stood in the way of covid
and we stood in the way of you getting
any money it can
could continue to massacre them into
2022 and remember that under donald
trump republicans lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate and the white house
in 2020 they saw
georgia go blue and texas go closer
to blue in the presidential election and
the republican party
really is at risk here and especially
now with donald trump
considering launching this new political
party it is a very
tender situation for the party we'll
talk a little bit more later
about the willingness of the republican
electorate
to abandon the party and to go with
trump we have some new polling
about that but as has been the theme
with the republican party for the last
four years much of this is unforced
errors
this all goes back to if trump had just
let fauci run the show
had gotten behind guidelines had offered
american flag masks for
republicans to buy and wear he would
have been re-elected
republicans would probably still have
the senate now we're talking about a
democratic president
with a higher approval rating in texas
than the republican governor
unbelievable stuff joe biden believes
that donald trump should not continue
receiving intelligence briefings and is
going to
stop them joe biden was interviewed on
cbs
evening news on friday nora o'donnell
asked him about this and joe biden said
he should stop
getting the intelligence briefings you
may know
you may not you may know that former
presidents
uh receive intelligence briefings even
thereafter uh even after they're out of
office
and it includes uh classified
information
but we have a very i don't want to say
very unique it's just
unique it's a unique situation in which
donald trump continuing to receive these
briefings may actually pose a national
security risk and trump
trump couldn't even be trusted with
classified information as president
of course he can't be trusted with
classified information back
as a private citizen and this is the
first time
that a former president is being cut out
of briefings
and here is joe biden explaining why
should former president trump still
receive intelligence briefings
i think not why not
because of his radical behavior
unrelated to
the insurrection i mean you've called
him an existential threat
you've called him dangerous you've
called him reckless
yeah i have and i believe it what's your
worst fear if he continues to get these
intelligence briefings
i'd rather not speculate out loud i just
think that there is no
need for him to have that intelligence
briefing
what value is giving him an intelligent
briefing what impact does he have at all
other than the fact he might slip and
say something joe biden's absolutely
correct
donald trump's intelligence briefings
should have been cut off
on the first day that he was out of
office something nobody is saying but is
relevant
is the question of is trump even getting
them
if he is is he listening if he's
listening
does he remember or understand the
content of them and then what is he
doing with that information
morally donald trump is exactly the type
of person
who would figure out how to monetize or
trade access to that information
if he came up with a way to do it i
don't know that he's actually
clever enough to figure out a way to do
it but trump is a sort of like who's the
highest bidder for what i know type of
guy
why even take a chance democratic
congressman
adam schiff has been talking about this
for a while he said a couple of weeks
ago days before trump left office
trump shouldn't get these briefings and
he makes another great point as to why
he leaves office he should be denied
access
to intelligence briefings would you urge
the biden administration to do that
absolutely there's no circumstance in
which this president should get another
intelligence briefing not now
uh not in the future uh i don't think he
can be trusted with it now
uh and in the future he certainly can't
be trusted indeed there were
i think any number of intelligence
partners of ours around the world
who probably started withholding
information from us because they didn't
trust the president uh
would would safeguard that information
to protect their sources and methods
this is a really good point aside from
what trump
will do with the information we know
that during trump's presidency
many of our allies were being more
careful about what they told the united
states
for fear it would get to trump and trump
would spill the beans
if they know trump still gets
intelligence briefings that might
continue
cutting trump off from the intelligence
briefings
not only is the right decision from a
national security standpoint
it probably helps revive some of our
relationships
including as far as intelligence sharing
is concerned with other countries that's
something that
is a big task for joe biden
re-establishing some of those
damaged relationships joe biden is right
to do this
and the official announcement about it
happening should be coming any moment
now
one of the things i've been talking
about during the last
year of donald trump's presidency and
during the campaign and
during the transition period and during
joe biden's nascent
presidency is that the republican party
at this point has stopped even
pretending to be about policy and values
and is merely about performative outrage
misplaced outrage laughable
outrage we're going to look at an
example in a moment but i think this is
an
important sort of reset to do and i know
many of you might be thinking david you
know the republican party
hasn't really been about policy for a
very long time that's true but they used
to pretend to be about policy
for a time the republican party really
was about
tax cuts for the rich cutting budgets by
cutting social programs
uh spreading spreading the quote
spreading democracy
through invasive foreign policy around
the world
they tried passing bills to get these
things done
eventually during the end of the bush
era and into the barack obama
uh presidency both terms the republican
party started to become
about policy in name only but not
sincerely
they went from really trying to do
policy to just talking about it but not
really caring about policy you know
they'd claim to be about
cutting the deficit and reducing the
debt and fiscal responsibility but
not when george w bush wanted to explode
the deficit by going to war
with the wrong country and they refused
to acknowledge when barack obama
did cut the deficit so they went from
being about a few policies
bad policies policies i disagreed with
to
only claiming to be about those policies
while not actually doing a thing about
it
and we saw more and more that the
republican party
became obsessed with grievances the
so-called war on christmas they were
fighting
fighting non-existent censorship
fighting non-existent depression
by gay people at what they called the
gay lobby rather than of
lgbtq folks that type of thing and then
trump
ran on policy terrible policy but he ran
on it
and then just didn't do it when he
became president of the united states
he ran on building a wall he didn't
build it he ran on replacing obamacare
with a beautiful new health care plan
plan never existed i think we're still
two weeks away from trump unveiling it
even though he's out of office
he ran on paying off the debt in one
term he did the opposite
and over the presidency of donald trump
the republican party went from
being about these bad policy ideas to
being about the news is fake
you can only trust us everybody else is
lying to you democrats are censoring you
and uh social media is censoring you and
us they're being unfair to trump
they're canceling thanksgiving they're
canceling christmas they're canceling
the constitution
they're canceling you know covet
guidelines violate the constitution
and so what we have left today is a
trumpian
republican party that is about nothing
other than performative outrage
what policy is marjorie taylor green
about nothing
she barely even pretends to be about
policy because she knows nothing about
policy
and it's essentially a grievance
campaign what policy is madison
cawthorn about nothing and in fact we've
gotten reports from inside his staff
that he is running a communications
platform rather than a policy platform
we know we could tell it's all about
being outraged at the left for things
that don't even exist and right-wing
media has jumped on the train
probably because it's profitable for
them i'm going to play a clip now that
is the epitome of this
fox news invited a minnesota republican
state senator named julia coleman on
why did they do that because she's
furious
and fox news is outraged that minnesota
educational standards
don't rail against socialism enough
and that's the reason that she's
outraged take a look
standards have a stated purpose more
like that of the 1619 project
than that of maintaining freedom well
that it's all part of an evolution
that went from the civics department to
social studies
uh here's a here's we actually reached
out to the minnesota department of
education for a statement here's a
portion of what they said
they said the benchmarks listed in this
first draft are simply examples of what
could be included under each standard
historical us events like world war ii
and the holocaust are being taught in
minnesota schools we welcome senator
coleman's feedback as we
as well as the feedback of every
american so based on what you've
revealed
do you feel like they're fairly
including uh
portions of say world war ii and would
they exclude
them if no one spoke up about it if you
didn't expose this what would they get
away with
well quite frankly pete this is not
exactly true what they're saying because
5 000 parents in minnesota reached out
to the review board
stating their concerns and they were
brushed off in a recent meeting
now if you're having trouble
understanding what she's so mad about
and what fox host pete hegseth is so mad
about
it's because it's all a performative
farce
this is what the republican party in the
immediate post-trump era is about
nothing outrage porn based on nothing
now the question becomes and it's a it's
an important question for the republican
party to answer
how long can the republican party
survive on the platform of
baseless outrage for a while it will
work because you're getting people
outraged
but if they continue to be about
imaginary censorship
while voting against a coveted relief
bill that joe biden and democrats get
done
and it gets money to people and voters
know it
what does this outrage performative
nonsense
do for them in the 2022 midterms i don't
know the answer
and it remains to be seen but it could
be very very bad
and we'll talk about it a little bit
more later in the context of this
third party that donald trump is looking
at and which
64 of republicans if you can believe it
would be open to joining and abandoning
the republican party we'll talk about
that later
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation
is one of the biggest problems that our
society faces and
online filter bubbles make the problem
worse making it difficult even for
intelligent news consumers to figure out
what's true and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first news comparison
platform that lets you compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is mostly funded
by viewers and listeners like you
through the membership program consider
signing up at joinpacman.com and not
only will you know you are
supporting alternatives to homogenous
corporate media
you also get cool stuff including the
daily bonus show produced
just for our members sign up at
joinpakman.com
so you've got to see this stuff that
there's a growing trend which we
expected for reporters to ask joe why
joe biden's white house press secretary
jen sackey
tough questions during press briefings
that aren't actually tough questions
they're just sort of fake drama and
attack lines
and i'm the first person to tell you
that
every press secretary regardless of
party
should get tough questions real tough
questions
questions like joe biden promised two
thousand dollar checks right away
and we're three weeks in and talking
about fourteen hundred dollars
explain that's a real question of uh
urgent importance to the american people
but what i'm gonna play for you today
and what we've seen in the press
briefing room
for two and a half weeks now under joe
biden's presidency
these aren't real tough questions these
are ridiculous questions so let's check
out
some of these examples here is a
reporter asking
why won't joe biden call antifa
terrorists what are the definitions of
terrorists
and why is the focus only on january 6th
that
there was jake sullivan mentioned the
focus on domestic terrorism yesterday
for this administration i think a lot of
people want to know
how does this administration define the
term domestic terrorist
in what way well it does that include
antifa specifically what how
do you set those parameters for domestic
terrorists especially as we see you know
a lot of focus on the january 6
maybe not as much focus on some of the
extremism and violence in the north the
northwest
well i've answered a version of this
question a couple times before but i
know everybody's not in the briefing
room every day
the reason we have the review which is
not a political review
but is a review done by our national
security team something tasked
again to take a review of domestic
violent extremism
we'll cover uh uh incidents across the
board
you sort of get the sense that gen saki
deals with this the way a parent deals
with an
obstinate kid throwing a tantrum sort of
like
some amused detachment but still having
to
remain strict in order to control the
situation and not encourage bad behavior
and then a question that sort of tries
to paint teachers
as these stubborn adversaries refusing
to go back to school
and saki does a good job of not letting
the framing be
that teachers are bad and the enemy and
are gonna have to be forced back
those questions but go ahead will
president biden use the power of the
bully pulpit
to help cajole teachers who are
unwilling to go back to
schools to go back well
one i'm just going to reject the premise
of the question i will say
i have teachers in my family as i'm sure
many of you do
they are the first people to tell you
that being
teaching in the classroom and being able
to engage with kids in the classroom or
middle schoolers or high schoolers in
the classroom
it makes their job more enjoyable makes
them more effective at what they do so
she turns the question around
and it doesn't matter the reporter keeps
going and then tries to
incorrectly inaccurately summarize what
jensaki actually said
that sounded like a yes with an asterisk
i i
you if you are the spokesperson for the
white house you could certainly say that
but you are not but you can ask me
another question
my second quick question uh is uh last
year
these briefings are there's there's an
attempt to turn these briefings into a
joke
but for very different reasons than they
were a joke under trump's white house
press secretary kaylee mcinanni
another game that they're playing is
saying you know biden
said unity biden promised
bipartisanship but no republicans are
supporting the covid bill so
is this evidence that joe biden is
abandoning bipartisanship and unity
and jen sackey is receiving this
question all the time and she's doing a
good job answering and given the
president's remarks earlier
in his change of tone it does seem that
he is now okay if this does happen just
with democratic support despite those
hopes
and despite his calls for unity well
first of all the president
ran on the um uh on unifying the country
and putting forward ideas that would
help address the crises were
facing he didn't run on a promise to
unite the democratic and republican
party into one party in washington
this package has the vast majority of
support from the american public
i'm fine with the question and she
should keep answering it this way but it
needs to be said really clearly
joe biden made a proposal and then met
with republicans to hear their side
to get their thoughts to get a sense of
what they want
republicans proposed something absurd
they proposed a package
less than one-third the size of what
democrats and joe biden want
and what joe biden and democrats want is
popular with the american people
joe biden has a 69 approval rating on
covid
63 approval overall you don't get that
with just democrats
trump never even got to 50 approval on
one day of his presidency
and joe biden's already at 63 overall 69
on covet
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink
joe biden engaged with republicans the
american people want something else
democrats want something else and joe
biden wants something else and it's joe
biden's responsibility to get it done
at some point you can't keep waiting
around for bad
faith actors so i guess this is sort of
how it's going to be
i would prefer rather than silly
non-gotchas
that they actually put together some
serious well-calibrated tough questions
that's what i would like to see
it's not clear that that's actually
going to happen
and uh as we saw uh very early on in joe
biden's presidency
it's not clear that you know the as she
points out
unity and bipartisanship don't mean
you have to give up everything to get a
republican to vote with you
when you have the country more behind
you and more behind these ideas than
they ever were behind anything donald
trump did
at some point you have to just say
listen we i i offered everything we
offered the meetings we offer
what they want is ridiculous we're not
going to do it it's not what the
american people want
at a certain point you have to do that
it's your responsibility and i hope that
that's actually what joe biden is doing
now
hey this is super super interesting the
top
rated program on fox business
the lou dobbs program has been canceled
blue dobbs tonight is the name of the
show
now most of you i'm i'm guessing know
about fox news
fox business is sort of like the less
well-rated little sister or brother
to fox news and the most popular
show on that channel was lou dobbs
tonight
lou dobbs has been canceled abruptly
uh fox business network announced
on a friday that lou dobbs program
is effective immediately off the air
there's going to be an
interim show starting on monday
and it's weird because this is the
highest rate of
rate highest rated show
the channel doesn't do that well the
best thing they had going from the
standpoint of ratings was the lou dobbs
program
and now he's gone he often had twice
the rating of the show that led into his
show
that's really rare in television and lou
dobbs is
a veteran anchor at this point i mean
he's out of his mind when it comes to
his political views
but he's been around for a long time
he's sort of a known entity
and um what appears to be going on here
is that fox business as much as fox news
newsmax oan
they are very worried about legal
exposure
because of the absolutely uh
out of this world lies that were being
perpetrated
and perpetuated and uh spread by lou
dobbs and his guests
lou dobbs had the the whole uh what
would you call them the whole gang
the whole brady bunch on his program
sydney powell
and you know all of the people that were
spreading the election lies about the
election was stolen by joe biden from
donald trump all of this stuff
and so my reaction to this is very much
like my reaction
to republican officials from the bush
era leaving the republican party which
we talked about last week
it's very much like my reaction to
newsmax airing a piece saying
we believe the results of the election
or whatever
fox is taking this step because they got
destroyed in a nearly 300-page legal
complaint
about their election fraud coverage lou
dobbs was
as big a player as anybody in that legal
complaint
he was one of the primary promulgators
of the election fraud nonsense and now
they're at risk of serious financial
consequences
now i think uh so so as far as
ethics or whatever this is merely a
financial decision that's
it i think a question that needs to be
asked
more so i mean listen newsmax and oan
they are not what fox is in terms of
corporate
infrastructure will any executives at
fox be fired for allowing lou dobbs to
spread
this nonsense for month be months
because any one of them could have
stopped this
very quickly and they opted not to do it
until they were in legal hot water as
far as lou dobbs i don't know
i don't know he's no spring chicken
maybe he'll go in the direction of
newsmax or oan but
even they've been careful about the
voter fraud stuff over the last couple
of weeks for the same reasons huge legal
liability
now one other thought and we're going to
get to this a little later
over the weekend a whole bunch of fox
shows
janine pirro jesse waters a bunch of
others
dated segments on cancel culture they
didn't mention this
they didn't mention this i mean listen
this is a conservative getting cancelled
right
but somehow this cancellation doesn't
play well into the story of social media
and democrats and left-wingers and
communists and socialists and marxists
and whoever else
canceling conservatives but isn't this
what their outrage porn stories have
been all about
conservatives getting canceled except
this one's by fox news and it's for
legal
reasons of significant financial
consequence the fact
but oh one last thought this was the
highest rated show on fox business
that says a lot about what's going on at
fox business like what on earth is going
on at fox business that lou dobbs
is the highest rated show so my
prediction is we will see more of this
not because anybody's found a moral
compass not because anybody
of these wacky right-wing network
networks have all of a sudden decided
that we really need to value truth
uh no these are merely business
decisions and they are worried about
having to pay out a
ton a ton of money we'll have more about
this
on our instagram page which you can find
at david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pac
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
so this weekend fox news was completely
off the deep end in a hilarious amalgam
of calculated cancel culture complaints
and possibly even drunken hosts again
yes i'm talking about janine pirro so
let's take a quick tour
through all of it now i have to tell you
i expected right-wing media to get
really really nuts when donald trump
left and there were a lot of different
reasons for that some of them were
political some of them were financial
some of them were
the personal sort of uh uh
goals of individuals wanting to maintain
proximity to power in different ways or
whatever
i didn't think it would be this
cartoonish so first of all
judge jeanine pirro she's a former judge
and host on fox news
she hosted republican senator rand paul
who at this point
is comically not credible as an
individual
and rand paul asserted without any
evidence you know
because of joe biden and hunter biden's
alleged connections to china
if china you nuked the united states
joe biden might not even respond what
joe biden would do nothing if the u.s
was nuked what are you talking about
rand yes that's what he's saying take a
look
real question there has been question
also of hunter bidens and the biden
family ties to chinese business
and there may be something that they
consider that they have an end with the
bidens that will cause them
uh not to respond to any kind of nuclear
aggression
i hope not now of course that claim was
was made as you can probably tell
completely without any evidence
whatsoever the idea that biden would do
nothing if china nuked the united states
is so absurd
as a thing for a sitting senator to say
that
the discussion we should be having is
whether rand paul
could should or can be expelled from the
senate rather than whether there's any
merit to what he's saying
and then a seemingly drunk again i mean
this is not the first time this has
happened
um an unbalanced judge janine pirro
talks about cancel culture
but fails to mention her own network
cancelled lou dobbs the day before take
a look
you're the weak ones you're the
unfaithful ones
you don't deserve a job with three
months off
so an entire segment about they'll never
cancel me
and canceling this and canceling that
shutting down the other thing
not a single mention of lou
dobbs being cancelled by fox news
that's really the only prominent
republican cancellation i can think of
recently
josh hawley not getting to do a book
with a private company that's not a
cancellation that's called business
um but no mention of the lou dobbs
cancellation then on another show
on this same saturday night jesse waters
who's another host at fox news brings in
dog the bounty hunter for political
analysis about a supposed crime wave
being driven by joe biden
even though biden's done nothing of the
sort now
dog is not totally coherent here but i
have to give dog
credit he didn't feed into the framing
of the segment as much as i would have
expected him to and he actually said
let's see what joe biden does i hope joe
biden does well you'll hear a lot of
very strange noises in the background
dog wearing
sunglasses i mean it's all very weird
but uh dog doesn't doesn't
jump in full uh headfirst the way i
thought he was going to
for more on this dog the bounty hunter
dwayne
dog chapman all right do you agree with
my assessment those four things
that are driving the crime wave and what
are we going to do about it
well uh yes kind of i agree i just don't
think there's that much gloom and doom
but
you know i'd like to ever everyone is
waiting to see
what president biden's uh
crime plan is we hope that he's solid on
crime and not
that he's uh soft on it we want him of
course to back the blue
we want officers protected
we want our civil rights protected and i
you know we're going into i'm uh not i'm
an optimist so i'm excited about going
into the new uh
you know new realm for america right now
i want to see what president biden has
got for
for crime and hoping that the
prosecutors are not all soft on crime
and let's see what he's got
right we want joe biden to be solid
and not soft but okay i mean thanks dog
at least he didn't come in and just
directly slander
biden the way jesse waters wanted him to
do
i'm guessing that's not the analysis
jesse waters was hoping for
jesse waters also did an entire segment
on the supposed cancelling of
conservatives so janine pirro did a
defiant
segment about cancellation jesse waters
did a segment about
cancellation of conservatives lo and
behold
jesse also didn't mention that lou dobbs
just 24 hours earlier
was cancelled by jesse's own network
that apparently was not an
important data point in the cancellation
of conservatives
to make the segment then yesterday
morning
republican senator ron johnson goes on
uh
maria bartoromo's show and
uh makes all sorts of wacky speculation
is this impeachment all about we now
know that uh 45 republican centers
believe it's unconstitutional
is this another diversion operation is
this meant to deflect
uh away from potentially what what the
speaker knew and when she knew it
i don't know but i'm suspicious yeah so
speculation completely without any
evidence there and here's a bonus
segment this is ron johnson referring to
this is this is i've never heard this
before he referred to my
birth country of argentina as argentina
i i don't know why i absolutely love
this bonus clip for you from yesterday
morning
a study coming just the day before out
of argentina so
as you can see a lot of chaos
coming out of argentina affecting the
united states right now and i will be
calling my relatives to figure out what
exactly is happening down there i need
to know
really strange stuff happening on fox
news and fox news is in this interesting
little place where
they are trying to figure out
how do we what what are we there's
almost like an identity crisis on fox
news
on the one hand by acknowledging that
joe biden won
we lost a bunch of our audience to fox
to a news max and oan
on the other hand if we go crazy or
right
it's hard to go crazy or right without
getting into the types of conspiracy
theories that get you sued
uh like about dominion voting machines
smartmatic or whatever
at the same time if we don't go right we
might keep
losing audience it's not an enviable
position for me
to be where fox news is right now uh but
that's partially because
my morality would never let me work at
fox news in the first place so i'm
probably not the right person to be
commenting
but the next few months are going to be
very interesting to watch
the dynamics of right-wing media and you
know what there's a
excellent excellent book it's i don't
even know if this book is
in print still i was able to get a copy
when i taught that class uh that when i
taught a college class
about media literacy and other things i
got a copy of this book
called waves of rancor and is it ranker
or rancor
i never knew how to say that word in any
case the book is basically about the
history of right-wing media and it goes
back to talking about you know father
coughlin and
and how a lot of right-wing radio
started with the religious orientation
and all that it's very very
interesting and there are sort of like
these main eras
that are of significant change to
right-wing media and how
the right has used various types of
airwaves and methods of communication
for advancing their agenda we may be in
a realignment right now
and the realignment is a combination of
things it's the rift in the republican
party between trumpism and non-trumpism
affecting how these different media
outlets relate to each other and to the
real world
uh combined with the actual uh
repercussions that
some are experiencing for violating
terms and conditions on a variety of
different platforms so we could be
i don't know what the next six months
will bring i do think part of it will
will depend on
whether donald trump launches this third
party
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit more uh later on in the
program
hey this is very very interesting a
majority of the country believes that
donald trump should be convicted
in his second impeachment trial which
starts tomorrow tomorrow february 9th
is the beginning of the second
impeachment trial of donald trump in the
senate
and a majority of americans now say that
they support
a conviction for donald trump in the
senate and that they support trump being
banned from holding federal office again
in the future this is a new abc news
ipsos poll released yesterday these are
very different numbers than we
saw during donald trump's first
impeachment in the abc news washington
post poll
published in late january of 2020 that
was
the first impeachment trial 47 percent
of americans
then said trump should be convicted and
removed from office by the senate
in this latest poll 56 percent of
americans say that donald trump should
be convicted and barred
from holding office and uh this is
notable for a few different reasons most
importantly because in the united states
you don't get 56 percent when it's only
democrats i think i i don't have the
latest numbers in front of me i think
democrats only make up about
it's in the low 30s i believe uh of the
united states the low
30s percent are democrats meaning to get
to 56 you've got
a bunch of independents as well as uh
some republicans in there as well so 56
say convict
trump um and we are going to see
i i i don't believe there's any chance
we get a conviction but we are going to
see another example
of how the will of the people is not
reflected
in what our elected officials do now
i've spoken before about how
the senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic to begin with
the senate with two senators from each
state regardless of that state's
population
allows senators who represent only 17
percent
of the population to control the
majority
of the votes or in some cases when 60
votes are needed
to prevent the majority from actually
getting their way
so the it is it is a fundamentally
anti-democratic body
and it's important to remember that you
know the q anon wing of the republican
party doesn't care that 56
of the country wants trump convicted um
republicans who have already
pre-judged this impeachment trial and
have already decided they're not going
to vote to convict
they're not going to be swayed by what
their constituents think come on guys
swayed by what their constituents think
they're they're going to be swayed by
the interests of the party and their
donors um
and this is
we talk about the major issues in
american politics and sort of in the
united states
and of course campaign finance and how
elections are financed is a big part of
that
the election system meaning the
electoral college plus first past the
post is a
big issue climate change is of course
a big issue and generally speaking
income inequality access to health care
because
if you don't know where your next meal
is coming from or you're sick and you
can't afford care
it's hard to be an activist for anything
that you care for
implicit in all of this is a belief
that many of us hold that representative
democracy
needs to be representative of the people
and we have
acutely a situation now princeton has
studied this we talked about it with tom
hartman
on the program last week we have yes an
oligarchy
but we also don't have representation
in the sense that most of us understand
it should work
the majority of americans want more
stimulus checks
and they believe that the plan joe biden
has put forward is
the right plan they support that plan
and they support health care reform
and they don't think we should be
involved in many of the military
conflicts we're engaged in and it just
has it just doesn't matter because
politicians are representing who someone
else they're representing donors
they're representing lobbyists they're
representing industry they're
representing elites or whatever the case
may be
and a majority of americans increasingly
are not getting
to decide now if everybody voted and not
only if everybody voted but they were
informed
you would be able to fire some of these
people but unfortunately due to a lack
of
media literacy political awareness
apathy
people being busy living their lives
which i also understand the system gets
perpetuated and we increasingly have
a non-democratic apparatus
representing the people bigger issue
than we can fix today
but uh we will be covering the trump
impeachment trial
starting tomorrow most of the country
wants trump convicted
it's not going to happen you know i'm
not going to lie to you i didn't lie to
you in january of 2020. we knew trump
wasn't getting convicted
trump's not getting convicted this time
either now i know some oh but
that that's the one other thing i wanted
to say secret ballot
a lot of people writing to me saying
david if there were a secret ballot
would trump get get convicted
maybe but it's not going to happen and
we'll talk about why a secret ballot
won't happen
maybe on tomorrow's show the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so we're continuing our
conversation about the possible future
or futures
of the republican party in this time
when they've stopped even pretending to
be about issues and policy and as we
talked about earlier in the show they've
become the party of performative
outrage what about that new
party that donald trump might start are
there
a lot of republicans who would abandon
the republican party and follow trump
or would it be an exercise in futility
well we have a poll
about this and the numbers are a
disaster
for the republican party 64 percent
of registered republicans nearly
two-thirds of registered republicans
said as of the last few days of january
that they would leave the republican
party
and join a new party led by donald trump
if he were
to do that now very interestingly
28 of independents and 15
of democrats also said they would likely
join a third party led by donald trump
um so what yeah
the first takeaway is how on earth
do 15 of democrats end up liking the
idea
of following donald trump to a kooky
third party that's not a great sign for
democrats
it implies that a significant portion of
democratic support is what we would call
soft
support and we probably many of us
inferred that
uh some some years ago but it is yet
another indication that at least some
support of uh
of democrats for their own party is
quite weak and they would abandon ship
but 15 of democrats is nothing compared
to 64
of republicans the bigger problem for
republicans
is now that we are several weeks post
donald trump it is still for now
the party of trump uh and of course
if donald trump launches his own party
it would almost ensure disaster for
republicans at least for one election
cycle but probably for more
and i love the idea and i hope it
happens i mean we you know we talk about
a third-party party spoiler effect
when a third-party candidate has a min
a uh 1 2 in some key states
a third party spoiler like we have never
seen before
would be possible with 64 of the
republican party
being willing to leave the republicans
and follow donald trump now
let's be very very honest with ourselves
there's no doubt that some of the 64
percent
in the poll who said i would leave the
party and follow trump
they wouldn't actually
they they maybe like the idea of it
right now or they're saying that that's
what they would do
in order to you know alarm the
republican party and the republican
party should be very alarmed
but i don't think 64 of the republican
party would
actually abandon it and follow donald
trump but it could be 50
it could be 45 it could be 58 any of
those numbers i mean even 25 percent
abandoning
would uh destroy the republican party
for at least one election cycle
if not more um if you're wondering by
the way
why um we've seen
the republican elected officials mostly
start kissing trump's ass after the
january sixth insurrection and since he
left
it's because of these numbers and you
know marjorie taylor greene and these
people
are completely out of their mind they're
radicals they're terrible for the
country but when they say
this is still the party of trump when
they say trump still has our support
he still has the support of the party
they're right
they're absolutely and completely right
and that is what these numbers
show us so i hope donald trump does do
this
um i it would be the exact cover that
democrats could use
to just have republicans too busy to
obstruct joe biden's policy ideas it
would be absolutely delightful
i fully support donald trump starting
another party
uh one of the sort of fun things to
watch lately and it's fun in the sense
of
of it being uh disaster porn quite
frankly it's been to see not only the
radicalization of right wing
media like newsmax and oan but also
seeing the low rent
characters that have been introduced to
us through these networks so
we've come to know people like sydney
powell and lynn
wood uh mike lindell from my pillow or
as i like to call him
mike pillow uh the various hosts and
reporters on oan
and newsmax who either couldn't get jobs
at syria's news outlets or used to work
there and were laid off or quit or got
fired or whatever the case may be
i have a new one for you today all right
newsmax interviewed a woman named rachel
hamm that's with two
m's h-a-m-m rachel hamm is a
barely known radical right-wing
christian
i have no idea why newsmax even wanted
to interview her
but they did and she went on air and she
said donald trump has been the best
thing for christianity since jesus
yeah like jesus christ you know the guy
um
listen to this she is responding to
claims that some have made
that donald trump has not been a good
christian nor good for christianity
rachel hamm believes he has been great
in fact a catastrophe for christianity
well i have to laugh president trump was
the best thing to happen to the
christian church in america
since maybe jesus so yeah that's
ridiculous i read the article
i thought if it weren't i don't know i
didn't know if he actually believed
the things he was saying but he is not
in touch with what the evangelical
church thinks
at all so okay trump the best thing for
christianity since jesus
it sounds sort of weird but
this is a woman who's been invited to
speak so she must know what she's
talking about right
i don't know i have no idea why she's on
tv um
we researched rachel hamm she has a
youtube channel with
23 000 subscribers okay
she wrote a book called life beginning
which is about her connection to god and
she has a website where she sells
online courses and ebooks
and she will give you advice and this
type of thing so
i don't know what's more sad that
this is the person that newsmax was
able to get to talk about how great of a
christian
donald trump is or was or that newsmax
is even willing to have rachel ham on to
make these claims like i don't know
who's dragging down whom i it's not
completely clear to me
and this by the way is another example
of the unhealthy level of
idolizing politicians that i've been
warning about for years now
i've warned the left and right about
this when i saw cults of personality
developing around
tulsi or andrew yang or bernie whoever
like agree disagree with people's
politics i think it's a bad idea to
deify any politicians that includes the
left and the right
this is taking it to the extreme the
best for christianity since jesus this
is very very
i mean again i you know these seem like
sick people to me to me this doesn't
seem
like uh it's someone who's emotionally
well placed within the within the world
but so much like we've been talking
about the republican party becoming
uh more about performative outrage this
is another
element of modern republicanism that is
either going to destroy the party
or they'll have to rule it root it out i
don't know that this is a party
that i mean you know a lot of us
obviously don't take people like rachel
ham
nor newsmax seriously as it is but to
the extent that newsmax will play a role
in the modern right-wing movement and
the republican party or the trump party
if trump is
decides to create a third party um this
is not going to be you know you and i
might say it's it's obviously
humiliating
they won't see it that way but i still
don't think it's useful
because there are republicans who find
this type of nonsense just
not good politics they think it's
unproductive for them and that's often
that's often the strongest word they're
willing to use it's not productive
sort of like susan collins being
perpetually disappointed by what donald
trump did
it's kind of a toothless uh phrase
but in any case it is going to be a drag
on the republican party and this is this
is a real challenge i don't
you know for years we've been hearing
demographic shifts mean
republicans will never win texas again
and like so far they keep winning texas
maybe at some
point the demographic shifts will take
texas from republicans
this combination of factors seems very
serious
64 of republicans willing to leave the
party and follow trump to a third party
as we talked about earlier
um the conservative media audience
increasingly split
between fox newsmax oan and others
the trumpy marjorie taylor green lauren
beaubert madison cawthorne wing of the
republican party
increasingly at odds with people like
mitt romney not exactly a liberal
by any stretch of the imagination all of
these things together
really could spell disaster for the
republican party i hope it happens
and we'll continue following it hey this
is funny um
this is just a very this is a light
thing okay this is not
serious we've done a lot of serious
stuff today um
i posted a funny youtube comment
to my instagram the other day one of our
callers called in
and read it and it is even more
incoherent when you hear it
read it's almost like an audience hatred
mail take a listen to this
hi david you are a sweet you are
a fake news just like donald trump
said you don't bring the news you bring
whining right complaining things to
complain because
if you're not understanding this you are
not having a medical event right now
it really doesn't make any sense
i don't do what you want him
good want him to do it right now buying
is doing what you want him to do
so you're happy and criticizing those
people who are not sure
that this is what needs to be done right
and yeah trust me i looked at it several
times before posting it to my instagram
and it still somehow made more sense
then
than it does now actually hearing it
read out so that
that is really something else i love
that we have a great bonus show for you
today
uh we are going to be previewing our
coverage
of the second impeachment trial of
donald trump which starts tomorrow i
don't even know
what time yet i've been so busy today
i'm guessing
10 a.m maybe eastern i don't know i'm
just guessing but in any case
we'll figure out what time it starts and
we are going to have
very very powerful coverage for you and
much more on today's bonus show
remember that to get instant access to
the bonus show
you need only sign up at joinpackman.com
very easy there is a coupon code the
coupon code
saves you a lot and the coupon code is
better 21
it could be all caps a lower case
a mix of the two it is not case
sensitive
but it must be spelled correctly that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-21
no spaces whatsoever i would love to see
you
on today's bonus show otherwise i will
see you tomorrow
new show and of course of course of
course
impeachment coverage live on youtube
twitch and facebook um and then after
tomorrow we will be on vacation for
three months
so i will see everybody then that's a
joke by the way
people get mad when we go on vacation we
really don't take that much vacation but
we're here all week all right i'll see
everybody tomorrow
or hopefully on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors unbiased news is
a myth
ground news is a news comparison
platform that empowers you to see how
the political biases of different
sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground